and the multiple criminal probes
involving former president Donald Trump
the former president's lawyers showed up
in person at the justice department in
D.C yesterday for a meeting including
the special counsel Robert Costa is
following that good morning Bob what are
we learning Good morning Tony three of
Trump's lawyers were seen by CBS News
Monday morning entering the justice
department to meet with top officials
including special counsel Jack Smith
sources say Smith's presence during the
nearly two-hour meeting underscores the
seriousness of the discussions as he
weighs whether to bring criminal charges
against Trump in recent months the grand
jury has heard testimony from dozens of
people close to Trump about whether he
or his age tried to obstruct the
government from recovering the
classified records from his Florida home
sources with knowledge of the probe say
the investigation is now likely in its
Final Phase with Smith in the process of
hearing out arguments from Trump's
attorneys CBS News has learned they told
doj officials that they believe the case
is flawed do due to the way
attorney-client privilege matters have
been handled especially a judge's ruling
that voice memos from one of Trump's
lawyers could be included as evidence
the former president defended himself
shortly after the meeting on his
platform truth social claiming he should
not be charged since he did nothing
wrong the special counsel who has not
spoken publicly about the case has given
no indication that he's backing away
from considering an indictment Gail
all right so it continues thank you Bob